Wall Street hopes to rebound today after
yesterday's historic losses but traders
are still thinking about the long-term
impact of this outbreak CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger joins
us Jill good morning what more Jill can
the government do at this point in the
midst of what one firm called a profound
profound pervasive persistent
contraction that's going to go on
indefinitely at this point well I think
the most important part of this is to
provide relief to the people who are
really suffering those could be the
folks who are laid off seeing a
reduction in hours those are the people
who need paid sick leave they need money
to take care of their sick relatives now
you're absolutely right we're in
uncharted territory here we have never
seen an economy just go full stop slam
on the brakes and now here we are we
just don't know where we're going next
and I think that's what really
contributes to the uncertainty in the
markets and is also really confounding
to economists we don't have data yet
that confirm how bad this is going to be
what we do know there are gonna be
millions of Americans impacted millions
of people who work in small businesses
who are gonna need help the business
owners and as you note the industries
themselves yeah there may be a necessary
slowdown in economic life in order to
protect public health but for the people
who are affected by the economic
downturn what's the best fix we just
heard that idea of maybe $1,000 a month
every American Mitt Romney is behind
that idea seems to have support across
the aisle is that the right fix well I
think there's got to be a couple of
things here we need a big bold package
again this economy just stopped if you
go back six weeks from where we're to
today it has that as if things have
turned around 180 degrees what we need
we need a package for that we'll deal
with all different levels remember there
are people who may say a payroll tax cut
that's only great if you are actually
working so we need to focus on the ones
who are actually out of work Jill how do
you stimulate an economy when you're
telling people essentially don't go
outside right well I I don't think you
are trying to I think that we are in the
exact
phase of the with the economy as we are
with this pandemic meaning we are done
with containment we're in mitigation and
mitigation with the economy means making
sure people have what they need you are
not going to convince people to go out
and spend but we do have the ability to
make this period much better for those
who are impacted most that's what the
government's role is here alright Joe
thank you very much